you know Barack Obama what he does so
well is that he translates compassion
and empathy and emotion positive emotion
is what Barack Obama does so well he
inspires he motivates in some ways he's
you know watching Hillary Clinton and
Barack Obama on the on the primary trail
you saw two heavyweights really going at
it in terms of campaign heavyweights and
also a campaign team both of them were
excellent communicators with excellent
strategies they need to go in different
directions based on their natural
attributes in some ways Barack Obama
stole the theme of Bill Clinton in 1992
change in hope and without that theme
Hillary Clinton had to go in a different
direction about experience and and
really focusing on some of the types of
fear appeals that Republicans have used
so well in in the past but if you notice
just like in a science debate what the
media was covering and what the public
was most interested in was not in the
complexity of the policy issues or the
policy differences between these two
candidates it boiled down to information
shortcuts and heuristics about character
experience race gender religion and most
of the strategic messaging and
communication were around those
attributes and appealing to those
original